today's video is sponsored by surf shark
i believe in cheating respectfully i
never tell my man like oh you can go
cheat on me
so cheating respectfully to me is
cheating where i don't find out
is having control over your other women
is using condoms and not having babies
like
treat respectfully because believe it or
not young man is cheating
but i'm not leaving my man over a
one-night stand with a
period i'll only leave my man for three
weeks three things you bring me home
spd you have a baby on me or if you gay
everything else is worked out
for me i'm glad the fact that him being
homosexuals reasonably
makes i mean
um what do you think is there a way to
cheat respectfully
it's not what you do it's how it's done
but it's not
if it's part of the clauses then it's
not cheating you know i mean
if you're okay with it it's not cheating
because you didn't go outside the
clauses
of what you had in your relationship
that's it right it's not cheating it's
exercising his options
no it's not just like you're stupid but
it's just high value men
don't cheat they just exercise their
options
like whatever you got
what are the claws of your relationship
you know right now we have options
what are the clauses of your you being
together
that's it that's what that's what it is
that's really what it comes down to
here here's the thing i suspect that the
problem with this is that
she don't want to encourage it but she
don't want to know right
yeah if you're playing me keep it on the
look but that but that's
because her heart can't take it anymore
i don't wanna know
if you blame me keep it on the lows
get thinking animal classic song classic
song but
if you [ __ ] you better
okay so before i start trolling what i
was trying to say is people don't even
want to have that conversation they're
saying if you're going to do something
that you know is going to upset me just
don't let me know yeah and do it in a
way
that doesn't it doesn't get back yeah
right but i don't think they're
relating this to the partner do you
think they should should what
that's a conversation you should have
with your partner if you open to that
kind of stuff well yeah
it is if you're open to that make it
make it clear yeah
make it clear what your classes are
definitely yeah i mean cheating by
definition is
is is you can't do it respectfully
because it's like a disrespectful act
it'd be like asking like is there a way
i could slap you respectfully i mean
unless it's in a bedroom type concept
like no
by definition the the idea of lying in
that regards is always going to be
disrespectful i like him when he beats
me
but respectfully like put a glove on no
you're beating
please put some street fighter music
round one
[Music]
yo guy was never a character i picked
but the music was fired yo
like that i've never been to america but
we've seen gala i've never been to
america
when i was a kid when i was watching oh
okay but when i would hear that song
that made me want to like sign up as a
soldier no you felt patriotic for no
goddamn reason yeah you were like yo
i'm a whole kid from canada who needs
some freedom wanting to join the army
[Music]
it gave me that thought gave me hope
yo that song gave me hope for no goddamn
reason hell yeah
yeah good song good song yeah yeah that
game changed it made me think that all
indians were long-lived
you know what i'm saying yoga flame but
anyways all this to say right i don't
think there's a respectful way to do it
necessarily since the dawn of man
there's always been some understandings
between a lot of men and a lot of women
who are winning relationships and
marriages
where one or the you know one or both of
the partners may have
steps outside of the marriage for some
needs if you will and
those relationships have gone on and
born grandkids and happy families per se
and i think i think when i hear this it
kind of just speaks to that
to that history like for some people
this works you know
but i just wouldn't call that cheating
if you have an understanding with that
person and you guys are on the same page
it's not cheating
cheating means that they they basically
defy the rules that you set within a
relationship
right you sleeping with somebody else
isn't cheating necessarily not
necessarily right
it depends on the understanding that you
have with the person exactly
right today's video is sponsored by surf
shark vpn
so vpn is basically an application or
web extension
that you could use on your web browser
or on your internet to mask
your ip address basically hiding your
location from whatever website you're
interacting with
now you might think why would i want to
hide where i'm at it doesn't matter well
unfortunately there are places that
block you based off of
your ip address and so if you're trying
to view
online content on let's download certain
things based off where you live
those things could be restricted now i
like watching tv shows
feel me sometimes they're foreign feel
me and
when that happens basically i use a vpn
to be able to bypass that so i can watch
what i want to watch because i feel like
the internet's at its best
when everything's accessible if you use
promo code abba and preach
you get 83 off plus three months free
so take advantage of the deal watch what
you want to watch and don't be
restricted by anyone's
barriers you deserve to go wherever
you'd like to go same thing and this is
common
in a lot of other cultures too in some
cultures you can have multiple wives and
some cultures are sister wives like
this is not a new phenomenon of like
we're not monogamous
or we are but then sometimes i get to
step out like this is it works for some
people
so as long as you have an understanding
with them then who am i to judge that's
between y'all the girls have sugar
there you go that's how i feel about it
but can you cheat respectfully
no no not by definition no not by
definition of the word but if you guys
have an understanding you're like you
know what
now if you're going to do that whole
thing there are rules right
no random kids out of nowhere right no
the knowing of the stds
right don't let it make to be the talk
around town be
private there are ways to go about it
girl you want to talk all the towns all
right that's my man face team sorry
about that
but you know this is not for everyone
some people are getting revolted by this
idea and that's great
it's not your relationship the same way
it's not mine i did it today do you
boo-boo yeah
i used
but you know don't buy the [ __ ] nut and
don't make her feel special right you
can't even do that
don't don't have a baby because she
can't be more special
okay so this comes to another
interesting point which is
which is they see a man building an
emotional bond with some other woman
as far more treacherous than if he had
made a physical bond with yeah
absolutely that's how i'd be thinking
yeah yeah like one of the first
questions they're going to ask the girls
are going to ask is going to be like
like let's say you
you you confess whatever something
happened do you like love her
that's the first thing because it's far
worse if there's love involved
then it's not because the love belongs
to me
but your body but your body
village but you know streets but that's
the first that's what i seen
my girls when they come to me is like yo
he did this and that and that whatever
and and they tell me yeah the first
question i asked was
what's that i'm like why why why is that
why you have to ask
like well it is perceived that that's
worse definitely
it's different for men though men it's
the opposite but did you [ __ ] him
that's what they're going to be
concerned with yeah because it feels
like you're tainted if you did
you know what i mean if it's the
different dynamics it's a different
dynamic different dynamics the
difference guys are going to be like
okay
so all these messages all these messages
all right
but did you and then nah and if you find
out that's where they lose it it's
really crazy
it's just a dynamic yeah not saying that
one person's perspective is but worse
than the other
i think we're just showcasing the
difference
in perspectives yep you know what i mean
yeah and that men
and women are different it doesn't mean
that one is better than the other one
but you can actually be different
and just be great in your difference
it's just different it's different ways
of thinking one is not better than the
other one
right one is not more logical than the
other one it's just
two different things i'm inclined to
agree let's move to denver and retire
together
no i know somebody that's still
sometimes people got millions they're
retired but i don't want that i want to
still have fun and build with my men
i want to build you want them to be
active acting okay i need a person that
values me
okay my person is at least six feet how
tall are you
i'm five five i like i'm a big girl
you're five five you're a big girl
you're a hobbit you're a whole hobbit
five five ain't big when you're a big
girl you start at five seven five seven
a girl like five seven
but five five you're normal you're the
norm
you're not a big girl you're five five
simmer down
geez you got a six feet sure
everybody got it i think it's just a
sexy number that's what it is
six it is it's a sexy number because
they would date someone was five ten or
five nine or five eight like they would
they just constantly say six feet
because there's a prestige behind it
because they know it's part of the
master race
so they always go ooh it is i want my
kids to be part of the master
it do be like that that's that's all it
is because if we rolled up on them
looking good at 5 10 they're going to
jump on it
it's like girls when you ask them to
describe their perfect uh penis size
they'd be like uh
uh this long just take your six inches
and stop complaining six inches is fine
trying to make me feel like i'm six feet
though cause you know the average height
for a man is like five eight
okay well average a for me but uh yeah
raising some interesting questions
do you guys think there's a respectful
way to do these things what do you think
about people who have these arrangements
is that something that you'd be open to
or would you never i feel like um the
kind of relationship she's describing
most people would look at it like
and they would definitely look down upon
that i see what you're saying i'm not
even going to clown her for that i see
what you're saying
the way she said it was maybe a bit
weird but
i see what you're saying i'm not even
going to go in
trash and nah and one thing guys don't
be saying stuff like oh my god this she
this is today's generation
make no mistake this kind of infidelity
these kinds of arrangements they've been
around forever the only difference is
now it's out in the open
what you what was once taboo and not to
be spoken of like voldemort
is everywhere who tommy riddle of all
the horse
so you know it's everywhere and i think
it's just
important for us to have honest
discussions we shouldn't paint the past
and
rosy images talk about my grandparents
trust me okay
a lot of your grandparents are straight
up blind they just stayed together
through the infidelity it was just
better at lying because that wasn't
normal
yeah so it's important to have these
discussions in honest terms let's not
pretend like today is completely
different but that's just my thoughts so
what do you guys think about what was
said in this video you guys agree or
disagree
i want to hear about you in the comments
below and if you liked today's video
leave a like
comment support share subscribe
[Music]
me